die Wassermassen sind über Nacht noch
einmal gefährlich gestiegen und auch in
den betroffenen Stadtgebieten in herson
laufen die evakuierungsarbeiten weiter
mit Hochdruck die Menschen fliehen aus
ihrem Zuhause mit gerade dem Nötigsten
die Flut sie kam einfach zu schnell
ich wartete hoffte dass ich bleiben
könnte
doch dann kam das Wasser plötzlich und
mit so einer Kraft das naja mein Sohn
hatte dann die Idee das Boot unseres
Nachbarn zu nehmen und so sind wir da
rausgekommen
wir saßen hier wir haben die ganzen
Beschüsse miterlebt und jetzt auch das
noch
der Staudamm diesem Ort der seit über
einem Jahr von den Russen kontrolliert
wird wie auch das südliche Ufer des nipo
die Überschwemmung trifft ein Gebiet das
viel umkämpft war in diesem Krieg
aufgrund der strategischen Lage und der
Nähe zur Krim die Wassermassen bedrohen
10.000 Menschen der ukrainische
Präsident spricht von einer ökologischen
Katastrophe
weiter Gebiete sind jetzt ohne
Bewässerung russland hat eine
ökologische Massenvernichtungswaffe
gezündet das ist ein ökozid
im UN-Sicherheitsrat in das beschuldigt
Moskau die Ukraine in der Nacht zum 6
Juni hat das Kiel für Regime ein
unfassbares Verbrechen begangen
gleichzeitig zögert die ukrainische
Führung nicht politische Schlüsse daraus
zu ziehen das angeblich für alle
Verbrechen dieser Art Russland
verantwortlich sei
internationale Sicherheitsexperten
allerdings sehen strategisch
militärische Vorteile einer Sprengung
des Staudamms eher bei Russland
es ist schwierig zu erkennen wie das ein
strategischer Vorteil für die Ukraine
sein könnte die Brücke und die gesamte
Straße wurden zerstört und im Fall dass
die Ukraine dieses Gebiet wieder
zurückerobert würde dies ein großes
Problem darstellen für Russland wiederum
lässt sich genau hier der Vorteil
erkennen
die Fluten sie reißen die Anwohner hier
in noch größeres Unglück als bisher
wir machen uns große Sorgen um die
Menschen in den betroffenen Gegenden die
wir derzeit nicht erreichen können und
wir sind operativ bereit jederzeit mit
internationalem Konvois und Hilfstruppen
auch in Russisch kontrollierte Gebiete
zu gehen
auch die UN macht sich also bereit und
selbst wenn das Wasser in der Region
rund um Person irgendwann schwindet die
Sprengung des kachowka Staudamms sie
markiert einen weiteren Wendepunkt in
diesem Krieg
und dem Katastrophengebiet in der
Ukraine unterwegs ist unser Reporter Tim
Kröger schönen guten Tag Tim ja wie ist
die aktuelle Situation
also hier in Carson finden den ganzen
Morgen schon Rettungsaktionen statt
vielleicht kann ich das ganz kurz mal
zeigen da hinten das ist gewissermaßen
eine Insel da sind noch viele Dutzende
Menschen die dort festsitzen durch die
Fluten und im Laufe des Vormittags
wurden weit mehr als 150 bereits vor der
Insel runtergeholt und zwar wird das
gemacht mit diesen Spezialfahrzeugen
unter anderem die fahren dann zur Insel
holen die Leute dort runter und kommen
dann wieder hier an Land und dann werden
die von hier aus oftmals in Busse
gebracht und dann weiter evakuiert wir
waren heute morgen aber auch noch an
einer anderen Stelle dort sind vor allem
ältere Menschen aus ihren Wohnungen
geholt worden die von den Wassermassen
umspült worden sind die sind ja nicht
mehr alleine weggekommen und das waren
schon beeindruckende zehn das waren
ältere Menschen die dann mit wenigen
habenseligkeiten die sie noch schnell
zusammengesammelt haben losgegangen sind
um dann wenigstens die nächsten Tage zu
überstehen viele von diesen Menschen
hatten ihre Haustiere dabei und ich gehe
davon aus dass diese Rettungsaktion
in diesen Rettungskräften hier im Laufe
des Vormittags immer mehr geworden sind
dass die noch eine ganze Weile
weitergehen wir haben auf jeden Fall
festgestellt dass über Nacht das Wasser
noch mal deutlich gestiegen ist im
Gegensatz zu gestern und der
Innenminister der ukrainische
Innenminister hat gerade eben hier diese
Stelle besucht und er hat uns gesagt
dass er davon ausgeht dass erst wenn
diese Wassermassen in den nächsten Tagen
in Richtung mehr abfließen und dann
irgendwann vollständig diesen Platz
wieder freigelegt haben dass man dann
erst sehen kann welche Schäden hier
wirklich angerichtet worden sind welches
Ausmaß dieser diese Sprengung oder bzw
diese Zerstörung des Darms wirklich hat
das ist gesagt gerade läuft erstmal die
Nothilfe was ist denn trotzdem
vielleicht schon in Bezug auf
Langzeitfolgen jetzt schon absehbar
naja das ist schon ein Thema nicht also
gestern war ja der erste Schock nach der
Sprengung jetzt aber am Tag danach wo
alle eine Nacht geschlafen haben
berichtet sich der Blick immer weiter
nach vorne ich habe es gerade gesagt der
ukrainische Innenminister war hier und
er hat uns gesagt das vor allem die
ökologische Situation hier natürlich
große Sorgen bereitet das beinhaltet zum
einen das hier sehr viel Öl und
Schadstoffe ins Wasser geleitet worden
sind oder ins Wasser gekommen sind durch
diese Überflutung dann gibt es natürlich
viele Kampfmittel die auch durch die
durch den Krieg hier einfach
mittlerweile im Wasser unterwegs sind
das sind zum Beispiel Minen die dann
wirklich Menschenleben bedrohen aber das
betrifft beispielsweise auch die
Landwirtschaft also viele
Bewässerungssysteme sind durch die
Überflutung kaputt gegangen also es ist
ein ökonomischer Schaden der hier
entstehen wird es wird befürchtet dass
die landwirtschaftlichen Flächen in der
betroffenen Region vielleicht schon im
nächsten Jahr wie eine Wüste aussehen
also das sind so die Befürchtungen die
jetzt auch vor allem von Seiten
ukraineischen Regierung gesehen werden
es ist anzunehmen dass dieser Dammbruch
diese Zerstörung dieses Stammes was auch
immer es gewesen ist diese Region hier
noch viele viele Monate wenn nicht sogar
Jahre beschäftigen wird Tim Krüger live
aus der Region in vielen Dank